hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused channel this is just a quick
mini video to answer a frequently asked
question that I get on my channel and
that is what is a lingua franca lingua
franca is a phrase that I use a lot on
the channel a lingua franca is a
language that is used for communication
between people who speak different
native languages here are a couple of
example situations of when a lingua
franca is necessary for example there
are many languages spoken in a
particular area or amongst different
ethnic groups and they need a language
to communicate with one another another
example there is trade between two
different countries that have no common
language example 3 at a professional
conference for experts from different
countries who have different native
languages on a global scale the current
largest lingua franca is English but
there are other various lingua Franca's
on a regional level and on a national
level an example of a regional lingua
franca is the French language in Africa
there are a lot of different languages
spoken in Africa and in a large portion
of the continent they use French as
their language of communication as their
lingua franca an example of a national
lingua franca is in Pakistan where there
are various different languages spoken
but who do the national language is used
as the lingua franca between those
different groups another similar
situation is in Philippines where they
have two lingua Franca's kind of would
they mix the two lingua franca sometimes
they have Tagalog and English and those
are used as the lingua franca between
people from different regions of the
country sometimes there are both
national lingua Franca's and more local
lingua Franca's within a country so if
we take the example of Philippines there
is a region where Ilocano is the main
language so someone from the Ilocano
speaking region meet someone from for
example the Bisaya
speaking region they'll probably use the
national lingua franca which is Tagalog
or English or use both of them but if
that same person meets someone from the
Ilocano speaking region who speaks a
different language like a minority
language then they'll probably use that
local language Ilocano as the lingua
franca because just in that one region
there are various languages spoken so
the lingua franca you use depends on who
you're speaking to so you're sort of
levelling up if you speak to someone in
your region you can
stand them use that regional lingua
franca if you speak to someone from a
different region use the national lingua
franca so it sounds all kind of
complicated but basically it means speak
the language that helps you communicate
with that person the best the term
lingua franca itself comes from the name
of a language that was spoken in this
way in the Mediterranean region for
hundreds of years it was kind of a
Creole Romance language that had a lot
of vocabulary from different
Mediterranean languages mixed into it
one English source from 1632
referred to this language as bastard
Spanish so to wrap up and clarify a
lingua franca is a language that is used
for communication between the speakers
of different native languages I hope
that clarifies things thank you for
watching have a nice stay